vladimir putin had a vision of a
decisive victory in ukraine
but his operation has stalled and his
generals have drawn up new plans
they say they'll liberate the territory
of eastern ukraine like the city of
israel and the communities which
surround it
but after four weeks of warfare the
residents now fear annihilation
schools and shops have been leveled and
family homes bombed from the air
mikola and lubov have lived in this
house for 32 years
what's the point of this
[Music]
foreign
okay
russia has had its eyes on the east for
years backing separatists in the region
since 2014
but its territorial ambitions are not
supported here i asked a local official
whether he was ready to be liberated
this school has been
absolutely
obliterated but it's not the only thing
that's been damaged in this village that
clinic has been shelled and
there are dozens of ordinary homes that
have been destroyed as well and it is
difficult to see any military rationale
for this
that's a question the people of israel
will ask
their city subject to weeks of intense
fighting with inner city areas now
largely destroyed we understand
an estimated twenty thousand are trapped
in this community cut off from the rest
of ukraine
we track down the mayor of israel in a
food store some 30 miles away
he fled the city two weeks ago but he's
still trying to help those who remain
it isn't easy the russians won't let his
team send in emergency supplies what are
you hearing right now from people in
islam
and they've been accommodated in
district schools and kindergartens
this one accommodates 19
and everybody wanted answers from the
mayor
will i have a place to return to said
the mayor said everything would be all
right
galena has been told that russian
soldiers are now living in her ism
apartment
my
the hours and days stretch in front of
them
separated from the people and the things
that they love
there is little comfort here and no
prospect of peace
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine